for the financial services industry
relative to say the crisis or the Big
Bang how consequential would a British
exit from the EU be I think this will be
the most consequential thing post-war
that we would have seen potentially I
don't want to go on about history too
much but the whole raison d'etre of the
European Union was politically inspired
initially the fallout can be controlled
but the political ramifications are
actually quite profound the most
consequential thing in the post-war
period that's saying something what
about for the City of London what about
for the financials it London as a
financial services capital well we said
before we're convinced that London
cannot not suffer in the event of a
brexit vote and the reason for that is
historic is that London has done very
well by virtue of being part of the
European Union its markets the exchanges
clearing everything are based in London
this has been challenged historically by
other members of the european union and
they survive because it does london seed
its leadership and if so to what city
well I don't think London will cede its
leadership and global financial services
per se but personally I think New York
is already getting bigger anyway than
London as the global financial services
center but if there is an attrition of
London's role in Europe in the case of
brexit which we believe there will be
then it will probably be some mix of
Frankfurt in Paris if you were to take
the total number of people employed
today in the city and envision a post
Briggs at world how many fewer would
there be precise I don't want to get too
specific on that but let's just say that
in our view that would be a material
diminution of employees in global
financial services in the UK what about
from Morgan Stanley we haven't got into
specifics obviously we're hoping that
the British photo will show sense and
listen to the economic arguments and
stay but we clearly are looking at our
plans now what's not clear is what the
effect of the reading renegotiations
will be in the event a brexit and what
that means for the single market and
Britain's access to it well
but if we may let's talk about some
practical concerns come Friday what does
Morgan Stanley start to do differently
that it isn't doing today well come
Friday what we have to do is this is of
course assuming you're assuming that
there's a brexit we have contingency
plans we will talk with our regulators
we will look at having a European
headquarters somewhere in Europe that
will be acceptable a to Morgan Stanley
and be to our regulators in terms of a
combined where would that be well it
could possibly possibly we haven't made
a decision dublin or frankfurt dublin or
friend i like the idea of dublin yes I'm
sure you do but you're biased yeah
what's most child in a Briggs at world
what's most challenging from an
operation standpoint I just don't know
whether we'll see the details yet what
will happen i believe is that clearing
of the euro will move to continental
europe the exchanges will be moved
because there will be allowed to pour
some element exchanges will move in
terms of exchange your products and
their the practical things straight away
longer-term you can have all sorts of
issues on movement of labour these are
travel and so on